it's not you please start off this very
evening by this time a TV sentence and
curtsied also kind of that my dear
friends tonight's event
it is very simply put on poster that we
see abundantly whether it was through
social media through a poster or through
the word of mouth of a very close friend
equality and equity equality or equity
this series or definitions have been
very much sing it out in different movie
winners there example whether if you
keep on speaking of equality these from
your mistakes of people especially in
says rights and opportunity however we
don't do the complicit you're pretending
these are talking about equity is
certainly not the value of shares is you
buy a company however it is truly the
value and tricks of behavior and
impartial equity energy all they are two
very important strategy you start
together exact same effort can make the
hurdle and achieve fairness however what
is the problem what is the problem when
it comes from religious perspective are
we talking about equality and equity
dependents are we talking about equality
equity between men and women I'm talking
about only in equity between two
different parties that are not related
here
now these questions are quite sure to
your mind that you're pretty much
already put in front please first sure
that all your questions especially
questions from our friends from
different faiths are very much
prioritize because this event is
demanding questions that can help us
reach a place of comfort and really try
as much as possible to make sure
earlier today in politics in history
which is currently doing research
University while it gets so the question
on equality or equity and whether one
intell's the other that's the crux of
the question is fresh in relation to
gender or sex or both and will come to
describing the sanctions between those
categories if there are this legs are
going to be divided into three different
parts inshallah the first part is going
to be an examination of the first
principles of feminism and of
traditionalist Islam the second part of
the
lecture will be what I deem our
inconsistencies in the application of
those first principles and the third
part of this lecture will be talking
about what's referred to as
intersectional feminism and that's going
to be an important part of this lecture
and it's important for the Muslim
community to know what that means
and how it can be effective both for us
and how it's contradictory in many ways
as well so to draw kind of like um a
generic sketch of what second wave in
particular second wave feminist
assumptions Intel and I've made this
point before and many other lectures the
idea is that there are biological and
anatomical differences between men and
women but despite those differences a
second where feminists would argue like
Simone de Beauvoir famously argued there
should be equality of opportunity this
is the presupposition now before I start
talking about this in more depth it's
important to note that feminism and
women's rights are not interchangeable
terms feminism is a political ideology
which most of which has has its writings
based in the Western Hemisphere
some say it's divided into three waves
and it has its own conceptions of
women's rights it does not have a
monopoly of that so you can have a non
feminist understanding of women's rights
and that's a possibility because to
argue otherwise we'll be arguing
actually in a circle or we had circular
argument so
when we say as Muslims that there are
tensions and contradictions and this
will this is definitely something we're
going to put forward today between
especially second-wave feminists ik
discourse and traditionalists Islamic
discourse this is an important note to
make that we are not saying that from a
traditional Islamic perspective from our
perspective as Muslims we're against
women's rights we cannot say this
because the Quran is very clear about
the fact that women's rights is a
project it's something that Muslims must
adhere to just like men's rights just
like the deity's rights allows rights
animal rights and so on and so a Muslim
cannot say we're against women's rights
this is actually counter textual it goes
against the sacred Texas this the sacred
texts for example where lots of Hanna
harlots is no Quran in the law halay of
the emblem and I mean come in Becker in
alpha Bob local min Bob that certainly
Allah does not let to waste any deed of
those who does good from you whether
you're a man or a woman and both of you
are from each other in other words there
is an equality in spiritual opportunity
between men and women and Islam and
there even is a general equality in
front of the law because the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu arias alum he says
in them and he said was a higher court
region and he said this in the context
where a woman was doing the prophets
wife was doing with law and she asked is
it the same for men and women so he
turned around he says certainly in them
and he sell she - agenda it's the same
for men and women women men and women
are equal in this regards meaning in
front of the law now this is a general
equality but of course the tensions will
arise when we say we'll hold on there
are exceptions
according to Islamic jurisprudence for
example what women wear is different to
what women what men wear there is a from
an Islamic perspective a justified
binary between men and women we should
start by saying that that we do believe
in the category of man and the category
of woman and that there are certain
regulations that apply to men that don't
apply to women and vice-versa
and those are the exception to the rule
of equality now if you pick up a locker
maybe a popular book on feminism like
this one when we go to in the UK a books
bookstore there they're almost like
right next to that where you're going to
pay the money for the book it's like
forcing you to buy it
what's this book a it's a it's a it's a
new popular it's not really an academic
work it's called the feminist manifesto
my Anu Ghazi she's very famous now in
terms of popular feminists and in the
front like things the first five pages
or something she candidly makes it clear
that we believe in an absolute equality
where there's no exception whatsoever
there's no exception whatsoever and I
think she made the exception of breast
milk and she talked about what breast
milk might be an exception but this is
that in the other right now this brings
us to our first point in examining
especially second wave feminists ik
discourse it's clear the premises the
premises there are physical differences
Simone de Beauvoir makes that candidly
clear there are physical differences
between men and women we know them we're
not ignorant to them
she even mentions emotional differences
in her book the second sex in her chats
on biology she says even biological
differences anatomical differences
physiological differences psychological
differences emotional differences but
the argument goes as follows despite
those differences there should be
equality
does that make sense so far so if a
second wave feminist would say despite
those differences there should be
equality afforded
what kind of equality political equality
social equality economic equality this
is pretty much in a nutshell what the
argument is now obviously one could
justifiably ask what's the proof of that
what's the evidence for that why should
that be the case how's that entailment
made from first principles Rousseff and
supports how can you justify that and
that's really not a question that there
is any answer to frankly well that there
is any formula given for us on how to
answer those questions however and this
is moving on now to the second part of
the lecture which I spend a little bit
of time on are we consistent or are
feminists consistent in particular
second where families are they
consistent in the application of those
principles now there are three things
three live examples I want to give you
to show you how problematic these
assumptions are for feminists the first
one relates and I'm sure many of you
might have been exposed to this it's a
big thing on the news now actually
that's why I'm bringing it up it's the
idea of transgendered sports now I'm not
sure if this is kind of them spill over
to Malaysia but this is certainly
something a hot topic in the West in
America and in the UK Western Europe the
question is say for instance you have
someone who identifies and who is
identified biologically as a man they do
a gender reassignment surgery and they
become self-identified as a woman okay
so they do a gender reassignment surgery
and they become self-identified as a
woman
can they participate in sports with
women now second wave feminists on the
whole seem adverse to the idea now you
can't make a generalization with
anything but big-time second wave
feminists like Germaine Greer who wrote
the book in 1971 the Female Eunuch she's
like one of the founding mothers of
feminism and she in an interview she
completely rejected the idea and guess
what she invoked she invoked anatomical
and biological advantage wait a minute
hold on now
hold on now let me hear the argument yes
so the argument goes now since the
person and this is a very sensible
argument to me as a non feminist right
the argument goes since men have
anatomical biological advantages
hormonal advantages and even haven't
gone through that process and then the
assignment the gender reassignment
happens if they now compete with women
it will give them an unfair advantage
and it will give them an entitled of a
privileged position in that context wait
a minute this is important now I thought
you said sex was not sex because that's
a third wave construct some say that sex
is a social construct Judith Butler
hinted to this in her book gender
troubles 1990 but not this some do say
that I thought you said gender was a
social construct no and you know it
becomes even more problematic do you
know when it becomes more problematic
when we start to see so the question is
now should there be an equality of
opportunity for men and women
in certain sports should we or should we
segregate and separate them you don't
like segregation but you have it in
sports but no no it's justified for
anatomical and biological reasons so
you're saying they're on biological and
anatomical grounds you can justify
separation well hold on now but men will
be given an advantage why don't you make
that argument in all context of
categories for instance if you look at
the 100-meter dash and I made this
argument before I make here again the
100 meter sprints in the last 100 years
I don't know of one white man who's won
that no I don't know I don't know of one
white man that's one that it's dominated
by black people no only just black
people West Africans and Jamaicans
should we separate the blacks from the
whites now if you say we shouldn't
separate the blacks from the whites
you're contradicting yourself you know
why because you said in cases where
there is biological and anatomical
advantages for one category of person
over another category of person there
should be separation so why should that
be the case only for gender why
shouldn't it also be the case for race
because you've recalled racist
this is selective invocation you see
they are not even consistent with their
principles East Africans are very good
at long-distance you know we have
someone called noir Farah very good
runner you know they have an advantage
East Africans both early they have a
broadening advantage white people have
an advantage in something swimming and I
want to be controversial but I've never
seen a black man win that swimming race
I was a hallmark of Michael Phelps how
many sounds is in you on it
while we're gonna separate the blacks
from the whites we're not gonna separate
the blacks from the whites so what kind
of record did you wanna so some
feminists would say we want equality of
opportunity and some would actually say
we want equality of outcome what all
right so yeah someone's saying we want
an equality of opportunity but almost
all feminists would say that in fact so
why don't you have an equality of
opportunity in sports
why don't we arrange parameters that
mean that people of the same weight
whether they're men and women they go
together in competition we could do that
it's not difficult it's not difficult in
boxing for example you don't think
there's 75 kilogram women that's the
most popular category for men let's
bring them together right you want
equality of opportunity no but that's
advantage men but the way he said the
anatomical thing you see it is really
problematic you have segregation
acquiesce segregation in some spheres
where are the feminists we need we need
a sign against this seriously if your
preview are principally averse to a
biological anatomical arguments arranged
parameters which does not discriminate
on gender in the field of sports but
they'll never do that because it's not
about equality
it's about entitlement it's about where
can we find the advantages that's the
problem
and this case becomes more exacerbated
when we look at war we need to rectify
the social ills problems of the past
patriarchal society and we need to have
equality of opportunity in all spheres
in all industries political social and
economic there should be absolutely no
exception to that but war that entails
death that entails injury we don't
really know about that one I've never
actually come across their movements
that aims to rectify a historic
accumulation of gender discrimination
against men in the field of war almost
every military in every country in the
world in all of history has been
male-dominated men have died now if
we're being honest we should say that's
a severe matriarchy you have force meant
to be society inclined or forced to kill
themselves and fight themselves so for
the protection of the country so on
feminism if there's an equality of
opportunity we should address that
historic discrimination and we should
look at all the walls now men were
dominating the armies in them and we
should have female only conscription and
draft forcing the women to fight for the
men for at least the amount of time that
would equalize the historic imbalance no
but brother
[Music]
what about the dangerous shows which
have been flooded by males men is that
HIV or is the actual matriarch what's
your color Mecca felt the need to go to
mining talks doing all kinds of
dangerous work the whole spa so if we're
going to go to the Equality premise
should we rectify that the problem is
guys it's just too selective you choose
want to be absolutely equal and you
choose you're in session this is the
father
so these are some clear examples of
inconsistencies even using the first
principles of feminism even using
exactly what they're talking about
now we've monogamous discussion I want
to talk about something which recently
has come about which is called
intersectional feminism and this is
coined a tournament was called by
someone called kimberlé crenshaw
and the feminists have had a battery
from different groups within because of
their colonialists and white supremacist
inclination so in the beginning as you
know the first wave feminism was
concerned with universal suffrage it was
concerned with giving women the right to
vote
which is a very not saying I mean I
don't think anyone in this room will
have any problem was that you know women
have the right to vote men have a right
to vote whatever other women vote myself
I don't care about voting but you know
it's not something we care about you
know you know the point is this
in the 60s many blacks preschool black
feminism kind of like a movement one of
the many people I think it's still alive
her name is billhooks she wrote really
books talking about the fact that really
the truth is the experience of second
wave feminism has been a white
experience it doesn't include the black
woman and it doesn't include the
underprivileged and so on and so there
was a hammering troop with him it was a
term folks was colonial feminism the
idea that this is actually the idea of
white women wanting to privilege
themselves they don't really care about
in their books and their arts was
enacted in academic pieces they were
making the argument for the woman of
color they were it was lacking in the
literature
laughing altogether of that figure on
the first where feminism was Italian
where British Empire but there was never
a cool for decolonization of the colored
things on me this country was colonized
by the British Empire that time wasn't
it or in 1957 them was a freed from the
shackles of colonial administration and
so at that time what about the white
feminists in America and in Britain and
in France saying well you know our women
in Malaysia in Indonesia in India in
Africa they need to be freed in fact
they were saying what was the things
they were saying now how can he keep
black people to vote before you give us
the ball and so on and they were making
racial comments about the Aborigines
about black people kind of things it was
a racist movement
to a large extent and explain this to
one of my lecturers called it stands at
that face of feminism on YouTube is what
to watch it is them and the duckface
or feminism some of the history of early
feminism but because of the fact that
they were kind of battered from within
right so a little forced at around like
say seventies or eighties or something
right to consider this idea
intersectional feminism and so
intersectional feminism considers not
only gender it says that the way a
person identifies themselves this month
primarily reduces agenda they might this
is true they might identify themselves
according to race they're gonna mention
religion fact about race class and
sexuality usually focus on those three
yeah
race class and sexuality yeah they will
say they will say that we have to
consider all of these entangled and
interlocking identify us we can't just
think about race or the kind of thing
you are definitely war we have to think
about gender in conjunction with race we
have to think about gender in
conjunction with class and so on and so
on this thesis I don't know you know
Sam here or something yeah who is
underprivileged in her all societies
years of the proletariat cheese working
class she's a completely different
category than a white woman they're two
separate categories of deceased if
they're two separate categories they
should be looked at differently
according to this that's true why are we
only looking at one parameter gender why
so the issue is the terms the sectional
feminism is a conservation because you
prioritize
[Music]
what who gave you the right to say
feminism there
why have you prioritize now the first
thing to say on their worldview they
believe in self possession and they
believe in self-determination would be
the first thing to say would be let the
woman decide for herself
watch the men decide from self what they
think
yes what they think are the most
important identifies for them in the
order that they think is most important
for them but this is a hybridization
which to do superbook's by colonial
feminist discourse in other words white
feminists in England and in the USA and
in France it's as if they're saying let
us prioritize your ideas for you the
most important thing you have to think
about your analysis is gender then after
that maybe is read that after that
lady's class and a masters will have
something different to say about that
and you know I ran into her have
and so on yes but what are you making
that high authorization who gives you
the right to try this I stand up no one
gave you the right you cannot serve it
you want to be fair you conduct a survey
yeah with him believe me yes and ask
them in order
what other things do once you identify
as the most so for example of the
polygamous a than one religion number to
Nationals number three German a
photographer then you have no right to
say to her that she should be a feminist
because I love you on her worldview
she has prioritized religion over above
the thing about intersectional feminism
is it has a propensity to
philosophically self-enclosed just like
the mothers so otherwise if you really
want to give someone the opportunity and
chance to make a decision for themselves
when they make a decision which falls in
line with a dominant discourse for some
source you have to remove that you can't
tell them now no you should always
prioritize this now what is there is a
tension and contradiction between what
feminists understanding of gender
Eurocentric understanding of gender and
Islamic understanding of gender which
there are what should the Zulu if she's
my taxes a slap on intersectional
feminism just to follow it
so the question we usually ask guys and
that is usually asked of us is how
accommodate for feminism that's the
question and they force people you know
no it's not the feminism this coalition
you know come to the society I'm also
doing it but the point is this well I'll
just say no all right so the witness is
right
if you give her the choice and she says
actually prioritize religion over your
conception of China then message the
question therefore how should this slam
accommodate feminism this is the
question is how feminism accommodate for
snap yes it's not how she slap when I
come to accommodate sorry okay
that's how that's my personal choice
I'm looking about to anyone and this is
hopefully what many women will also
agree with I hope they do whether it is
a contradiction we will prefer religious
narratives over and above Eurocentric SS
big ones and yes to another and if you
disagree with that you're against your
principles your colonialist your
agreement nourish will force your
fundamentals your fundamentalism you
have your understanding of pizza which
we've already shown a spoon but let's go
with it if feminism is true and fabulous
it was truly giving women the right to
self-determination then they should
allow a woman to consent to be in a
patriarchal structure where hidden that
sounds a bit like a boo right it's wrong
well the story is nothing if yes if
feminism proposed to give women the
right to make their own decisions if
they decide to live within biggest
constructions that is actually a
tightness embolism the she's made no
decision and if your job was to make to
make your own decision the job is done
leave us alone
your job is done if you want to feel the
space for a woman to make the decision
then when she makes a decision which
goes against your central axis don't be
disappointed
leave them alone don't be disappointed
that's how it is
if the husband can be powerful
what did you say now manipulate across
the table by the way this whole idea of
big obedience to the husband is a
caricature one yes it is no really this
control of the idea of a husband
exercising them tropical icing them and
the Muslims will be this woman there are
shadows and the man she is the small
happens in there this is justice'
squadrons in Islamic households this is
the capital ready ready that's what they
say something serious more into this
image obedience is severely curtailed
I'll tell you of a few things
some piece of stress for the Ramos
consider wrote about this and ethos
Islamic ethos the focus has left after a
group it's muscle car alone you cannot
obey the creation and the disobedience
to the traitor this is a very important
principle is too much because
unrecovered are overlooked do you think
that Muslim men and just a woman to go
and do this no it's against the Koran
I'm not gonna do it you do it yeah if
it's against the party has no problem I
mean you're only here to advise me on
what you think the Koran says I agree
with you I will yes okay if you say
something cool drink I'll come on let's
go updater and it's happened by the way
take your camera off someday use husband
so this is why so the problem here is
they think that obedience this idea
which spin
tropical eyes is fully interruptions now
it's not waba if you go she gets her ice
what does Mogens writes on a slap so if
you go for this couple
this is not marriage by the way
chica if she doesn't like money and
that's the decision that the family has
taken she could take that money for
herself
it's not a suit well that's why it was
by the way that's not for an affirmative
so if Jesus is I don't want to work man
says look you say we keep cool I'm gonna
pay off the bill you pay off the bill
justice I'm not really interested in
that because they will have to be
obedient to me no comment is under one
plus one of examples but there is an
aspect and there's nothing of such
religious or whatever girls gets her
there's no Tommy Morrison kissing her so
he says that we pulled up I don't know
we're the same this man G will be the
father or something and she's like I
love the boulder to obedience past them
you have to lift the boulder yes she
says you know at the moment when you use
the mother really it's tough nose huh
she goes to touch this Ebola Chancellor
you know she has from October it's not
this is what mine with accessories ha
mm what is the thought I'm talking about
well there's a consultation process
which is so nervous by the way and there
are some tenants right and then he
decides to over just internal issues
whether he forgets the quality my friend
there should be a perfect democracy on
feminism
there should be 50 50 percent decision
making this is the objection fifty fifty
percent is just amazing so what if what
would that create gridlock tell me what
polymer there in the world that wears
like
you did every partner tries to forge
photography even even the ones that
labels proportional representation
Israel assistant I think what PR
presentation although there's not the
focus today other reasons and I like the
relation you know that's or something
yes from YouTube say some of the things
about exactly yes what you used to avoid
it right so how we're gonna break the
deadlock oh it's not actually allows to
be said there are some exceptions who's
a powerful relationship wrestler is her
body they provide their process that's a
two dollar offer from some become for
SuperSpeed a my way this is interesting
I was reading some books of the Hannibal
addresses which is the the method I and
kind of follow for the most part they
says woman because we know the most part
she should be pays for that wrestler but
I married well yes she should also be
things buzzes from here with opinion
let's go go without it the idea is the
point I'm making is that it's poking
through Texas but there are cases there
are cases because a woman has certain
passages firefighter or mother as well
as messages there were technical
advantages and by the way mother is a
big kind of underscore the way finis
particular because they thought the
final so what's a mother someone who
gives birth to someone else or than a
foolishness and some cool differences
yes apology is it relevant ways they are
very clear that mom one that takes the
babies were strong enough what adoption
all of that is mother them right do you
even have a clear understanding all of
this
you don't have decided on it since you
company mother's rights if you don't
buzz off
but the idea is his son the mother is
the flange
what it gives birth to the child and so
when doing give birth to the child there
are certain rights that are afforded to
her by virtue of being a mother they are
not afforded to the man but she has the
three tiny pool Brian and software or
companionship were from the natal the
chaplain definitely gonna be in most
cases more influenced by rather than the
father how do you this is an imbalance
of equality is balance how do you
rectify that hurts so you give the man
some rice man
give him some rice women boost so it can
be good agreeable is with no even if
they say no this is our system the
question which talk also special today
is 38 minutes of lecture and I try and
keep things to maximum or 45 because I
know that the special session because
this probably is go some questions look
at me yes the question is to what it
says if any so neurosis is a piece of
him no evil to us except if any should
remove and biological differences as
well as psychological physiological ones
and counters for mobile society
prescription
two accents and they are found in our
looking at the first principles of
second wave feminism in particular the
answer is to no extent whatsoever they
should have absolutely no say but when
in application that thesis is presented
to them the first people to talk about
maternity leave a motion of the force of
society is the society my family signing
in England is the one that does it
without necessity was in discriminatory
practice in England one year for
emotions the year now or what they've
changed those of the that - two weeks
paternity all obviously disparity
let's hope based on quality and many
feminists derivative so love some
examples are counter to the absolute
equality premise and so reading is added
the thing we know with difference but
we'll take the advantages we will find
them Mormon
this is fallacious contradictory
problematic and that's why we say that
is why we say that Islam proposes the
following idea that there is an
all-knowing all-wise all-powerful entity
we call Allah who revealed and a message
to his final customers of our epsilon a
message which has all of the requires
rules and regulations regarding to
whether there should be an accessory we
both agree that this is the exceptions
in a way yes but the person is virtually
the exceptions be things like trust
rules for the most part extra
analytics of Russia in a public roads is
completely different
in taxes I remember what time just to go
to attention for the other time I was
closed in Leicester Square this in
central London who give him dollar to
the nominal speakers and so speaking to
The pieman petition to slammer trying to
educate people about statsoft and the
woman was there I think she's a bit
tipsy maybe they're drunk so she was
talking to me when I thought Miller she
talks a lot but she can do this and I
thought they were a few ounces if I find
that she talked contains this
conversation I'm trying to make it
should retreat so she said why is it I
wouldn't have to wear my cap basically
that was my question
that's it look I said but most of us
agree that anatomical differences have a
say in what we wear most of us agree to
that so socially and culturally the
right and I gave her the example I said
for instance in most cultures even
Western ones semantics of assuring me
summertime and augmentation for sure
when a man does it is seen as absolutely
noble to be honest with you yes
stop seeing us especially in London
what'd they take - sheriff in the park
no problem especially in beaches which
is a different paradigm together but in
my Foreman does it is seen as public see
if we don't agree with that
a lot of us would agree that and some of
them said we understand but the idea is
that if particular isin specified a slab
as a discourse of analysis if you have a
problem with men and women dressing
differently you should think about the
slapping because in your own culture you
have that that's the issue just that
that's the argument so the witness is to
finalize the discussion we spoke about a
fact
the Amazon all the differences despite
us trying to run away from as much as we
can have shaped everything almost from A
to Z even for feminists they consider it
very closely they recover the advantages
are and they strategically play on those
advantages probably the most consistent
feminists in this regard are third wave
feminist queer feminists and so on who
actually do make the argument for
example the trans example that a trans
person fact participate in the sports if
they have done the gender reassignment
surgery fact we talked about the
discourse
Muslim societies now seem to have
pressures on them Muslims within those
societies seem to be facing those
pressures to feminize and this should be
seen as a Eurocentric type of colonial
expansionism of ideological proportions
and we should realize that this is now
they are doing that at you simple as
that they are trying to invite you to
their way and this might well feminist
narrative of is compatible with Islam
and let's come in through you know this
means a song is a false one for so many
reasons we will discuss them for most of
the manual for most of the woman in
order to remove all cognitive dissonance
and cognitive dissonance is the idea
that you say one thing but believe
another and it gives you a psychological
kind of problem to remove that of your
life and it's a piece for mind
seriously you really do have to decide
to make the decision whether you want to
submit to the law or not just a bit to
the war Allah to the structures to the
mind Texas oh no and you can escape
sessional feminism as we've discussed
and they can't say anything about allah
but you have to have that decision made
in your mind and with that I will leave
the floor score 5 minutes exactly I
leave the floor gel off for questions
and answers